Eh
Oh
So it's been a while
Ima Naokatsu has blocked this block
Residents' experience is complete
Ryukaiin Hanaraboshi Saori It's
a wire trap like a dog breed
Satchel
Datchin
par
It's been a while since I've been like this
indoors  You're good at cqc or
something like that
Walnut Magical Truth Whitening Agent
No,
4 days
Hahaha Nande Magical Truth Whitening
Agent is magically strengthened barbituric acid
Whitening agent is in the middle
Target's consciousness is faint  I can listen to the necessary information chan It
seems that the East Asian Union teacher is a terrorist
Where is the
hostage?  basement isogo
a